the shells hit in the early morning
an air raid siren had warned residents
to take shelter otherwise this could
have been much worse
this is what the ground looks like when
a shell smashes into it causing damage
to Windows and walls of this apartment
block
what's weird because we are living near
of the coast on the border of the sea so
I think all people who has no any way to
go somewhere who stay here as they are
praying
another shell struck this house luckily
the owners were hiding in a nearby
garage at the time these apartments are
just on the seafront here and in the
early hours of this morning residents
said they heard loud bangs this is where
one of the shells landed and after the
explosion it would have sent shrapnel
flying towards this building you can see
all the little marks in the masonry
where it struck and the damage to the
glass that was caused
we walked further down towards the coast
and come across iriana and alessander
they've lived here for two years but
moved to a safer place just a few weeks
ago
and it's a good job they did because a
shell went straight through the front of
their home
I would love that Putin and his
propaganda spreaders when they are
caught before a trial to be carried in a
cage like an animal throughout the
country to show him what he and his
Liars did to Ukraine
the only feeling I have is gratitude
that everyone's alive and everyone's
here what can I do those in mariopol are
in much worse conditions
the Ukrainian military say this is the
first time that shells from Russian Navy
warships in the Black Sea have struck
Odessa the military here know that the
war is coming to them and believe the
Russians are testing their defenses and
their resolve
there are two important issues firstly
it is a demonstration of Firepower and
psychological pressure and secondly they
are trying to carry out reconnaissance
and find out the locations of our air
and Coastal defenses
Odessa has been expecting an attack of
some kind for weeks now this could be a
warning sign that more strikes are
likely Nick Martin Sky News Odessa